- [Mark] So Norman.
- Yes.
- [Mike] It's been a week or so.
How many days has it been since we talked?
- [Norman] I think it was
last Tuesday when we talked
- [Mark] So it's been a week and a half
- [Norman] Yeah about a week and a half.
- [Mark] And what's going on?
- [Norman] Well, what's transpired is
I looked at all the comments
and they were heartfelt.
They were very inspiring to the point
to where you're looking at a man
who has compiled eight
days sober as of today.
- [Mark] You haven't used in eight days?
- Eight days.
No beer, no marijuana,
no crack, no nothing.
- [Mark] Wow. That's impressive.
- I don't know if you guys can tell,
but my face is fatter because
I've just been eating.
(chuckles)
I've been eating a lot.
- [Mark] That's what happens.
- But I feel really good, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah. You sound different.
You called me last night.
You just sound like so clear,
like you could just tell.
- Yeah it's there.
I mean, and it was attributed
to the comments that I got, and...
- [Mark] Yeah, you got
a lot of positivity.
- And also that good word.
It was the wherewithal within myself.
- [Mark] That's my favorite word.
- And I said, you know what?
I really don't want to do this anymore.
I mean, I have people
who don't even know me
that listened to me and they gave me hope.
They gave me inspiration.
And I truly believe that
when your hope is reborn,
so is an opportunity
to transform your life.
So my hope is being reborn
and my self-esteem is being rebuilt
because you have to look at self esteem.
It's self esteem.
So therefore, no one else
can knock me down but me.
So what do I want to do?
And here I am.
- [Mark] That's great.
I think you were ready perhaps,
and this was maybe just the impetus
to get your shit together.
- Yeah, I think it was one of those things
where I had to really
talk about the issues.
One person had mentioned in a comment
maybe I need to see a therapist.
And I'm looking into that.
- [Mark] I think that's always great.
- I really want to, I really
want to do something better.
Also I have some other good news.
Tuesday, I have a video interview.
- [Mark] For a job.
- For a job as a property
manager of 11 different units.
- [Mark] How did this come about?
- Well, it came about that
day two of my sobriety,
I went on Indeed, I activated my resume,
and I said, you know what?
I don't want to be one
check Norman anymore.
You know, I want to be able
to be a productive citizen.
I wanna do something,
and maybe my talk can inspire some people.
Maybe I might get into a position
to where even if I get this job,
maybe a tenant has a problem
with a relative that is suffering.
And maybe I can add, you know,
some type of inspiration or some hope.
Or maybe they just need
somebody to talk to.
And, you know, hopefully
prayerfully, I can be that.
- [Mark] Well, of the
2000 interviews I've done
in the last 10 years,
when I was listening to yours,
it was just like this guy nails it better
than anyone I've spoken to.
(Norman chuckles)
And every, from every angle
when you mentioned
wherewithal, that was it.
It was like that was it.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I kinda put that as that's my word.
No, no one has ever really mentioned that
in any of my talks.
And that to me is the
most important thing.
Not that, you know I'm not a drug user,
so I don't even know,
but I know what it takes
to make anything happen.
It's not talent and it's not intelligence.
It's courage, certainly,
but really the core
of a lot of that in therapy
and getting the crap out of
your closet and all that stuff.
But the wherewithal, which
is the ability to do it.
- Right.
- [Mark] To get off the bed and
go do it every day is to me,
one of the most important things
that people don't understand.
- Yeah. An obstacle that
I have is, you know,
as far as housing is concerned, I mean,
I can stay with my buddy you know,
maybe three nights a week, you know?
So there's going to be
a point where I'm gonna-
- [Mark] But you've done this before.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You know how to
be a responsible citizen.
- Yeah. Where I have to,
we're probably going to
have to catch a train,
sleep on the train a
little bit, catch the bus.
- [Mark] Look at it as a challenge.
- There's going to be an obstacle.
And nobody says it's easy.
It's like a grand chess match.
You know, it's like, I've made a move.
Now here comes another move.
You know, it's not so much of
trying to get the checkmate,
but it's guarding.
It's that guard that I got to put up.
So I did call LAHSA.
I left a message.
Maybe they can help me as far
as some housing is concerned.
We're just gonna do it, man.
I mean, it's, you're
talking about 30 plus years
on and off, up and down.
My kids need me.
I did have a chance to
talk to my oldest daughter.
She was very happy to hear from me.
She told me she loved me and
that made me feel real good.
I had a chance to talk to my son,
who is the only son that I have.
He says, I don't give a damn what you do.
You're always gonna be my father.
And that was good.
And for you, sir, you...
You're almost, you might
be thought a photographer,
but I'm gonna call you a therapist.
And because what you did for me
is you allowed me to to
really get some shit out.
You know, because I didn't want
to tell anybody about molestation.
I didn't want to tell
anybody about, you know,
I let a guy give me
some head for some money
because I'm looking at what
you gonna think about me
and what you're going to say about me.
And, you know, image is everything.
Now I'm a homeless crack
head, but image is everything.
Well, guess what?
I don't give a fuck what you say about me.
What you say, think, and feel about me.
There's two things.
The most important, this
is none of my business.
The second is, you're gonna
say what you wanna say.
You're gonna be judgemental.
And if you're gonna be
judgemental in life,
you're probably headed down a bridge
that's gonna soon blow up.
So man, I just, thanks.
- [Mark] No, I think,
you know you're not the first person
that's told me they stopped
using after talking.
And it's not that I'm
doing something magical.
I think it's, maybe I'm
not very judgmental.
And that, that opens the
door for you to tell me
all kinds of dirt that's in your closet.
But it's that unloading
of all your baggage
that frees you up to go,
oh, I don't have to hide that any longer.
- Right.
- [Mark] And putting it
on a platform like YouTube
where basically in theory,
the entire world knows
now what you've done.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And that frees you up
to not carry that heavy baggage around.
- There were a couple of comments-
- [Mark] To make decisions
like you just did.
- Yeah. There were a couple of comments
where people were saying,
well, that's not the truth.
Then there was one person-
- [Mark] Every single one of
my videos on my channel is not,
I consider them, they're
not fully uploaded
until there's a comment saying it's a lie.
- Right.
- And then one guy said that,
he said, look him up.
It's true.
Look at his Facebook page.
And then the other guy
says, get this boy back.
He's a billionaire.
He's connected to Exxon.
You know, which a family
member founded Humble Oil,
which is now Exxon.
So I come from good stock
and you know, but sometimes,
hm how am I going to put this?
If you turn the pot off,
you're not gonna have a fully cooked meal.
My pot has been turned off.
God has empowered me to
reach over to the stove.
But when I reach over to the stove,
it's not me guiding my hand.
It's him.
See, I don't always
have to have it on high
to have a quick meal.
I can turn it on medium and cook it fully.
So I believe I'm being fully cooked.
I don't know where this stuff comes from.
It just comes out of my head.
You know?
So I just want to do the best that I can.
And we're gonna follow up again probably
because they're probably going to say,
well hey, we want to hear from Norman.
And that was really, really great.
I think, you know, all of my life
and being in the upper
echelon of companies
and things like that,
you never get a chance to really see
how people feel about you.
Now these are people
who don't even know me.
And really, really, that was positive.
And it turned me, it turned me.
My buddy was like,
Norman, are you all right?
And I was just sitting there
and got tears just running down.
He's like, man, what's wrong?
I said, it's over.
He says, what?
He said, I knew it.
I knew it was going to
happen sooner or later.
And it doesn't matter if he doesn't stop.
Maybe it's not his time.
And there's a scripture that
keeps ringing in my head.
Ecclesiastes 3:1.
There's a time, a purpose,
and a season for everything.
So I think this is my time.
I don't fully understand
or really know my purpose,
but it's his season and I'm
gonna do the best I can.
- [Mark] You've got
everything it takes, I think.
- [Norman] Yeah, well
sometimes it can have
everything that it takes
and it'll take away.
You know, I'm a very prideful person,
which now my pride is being stripped.
Because it's something that has been
not so much of an anomaly for me,
but it's been something that
has held me back, you know.
Of course, you know,
being able to travel
and do all these things
and come from this family and all that,
I've been able to, you know,
enjoy the finer things in life.
And there were times where I had
a very pompous, arrogant attitude.
In the Rooms of Recovery,
they say ego is edging God out.
I says, okay, well you know what?
I believe that God and I have
really settled our problem
because I had the problem with him.
He never had a problem with me.
And so I asked him, I
said, look if you're real,
if you are who you say you are, stop me.
Stop me.
And you just work.
You work in me and I'll work for you.
I don't want anymore.
I don't have a taste for it.
I could have money right now.
I don't want it.
I've been offered it.
One guy, he just couldn't believe it.
He followed me all the
way down the street.
Norman, what's wrong with you?
You don't want any dope?
Dude, what's wrong?
I said, man, I don't want anymore.
I said and I'll see you later.
And I remember walking down
the street about 20 yards
and I turned around and he looked at me
and he just shook his head.
And he says, okay man.
And he walked away, so.
- [Mark] And that's how you quit.
- That's it.
That's it.
I just know.
- [Mark] That's how you do it.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Because a year or two ago,
I couldn't get you to go to rehab.
I couldn't just, or somebody couldn't
point you to the rehab and say, go do it.
- There was a time where,
because I worked down here.
So a lot of people know
me and I've used down here
of course and done other things.
There was a time where
if you came up to me
and you were in recovery, I
don't want to hear that shit.
If you don't have anything to contribute
to what the hell I'm doing,
just get the hell away from me.
I wasn't rude, but I'd let you know,
Hey, look, you know, I'm
doing this right now.
You know, now you got
10, $15 to help me, fine.
If you don't, goodbye.
Cause I'm going back
over here and sit down.
And please leave me alone
because you're ruining my high.
So I just want to do the best I can.
And then, you know
you can't ask for anything
else or anything more, really.
You just, you go.
Gotta have that wherewithal.
I'm gonna mess around and
get a fuckin' t-shirt,
put wherewithal on it.
And I'm gonna put wherewithal
and I'm gonna put the number one on there
because it's gotta be in here.
And I'm gonna tell you something.
I had six years, 10 months
and two days before.
And I remember that.
I remember how arrogant I
got in things like that.
And then I fell.
But you know what?
I've never felt like this.
Even in those six years,
10 months, and two days,
I didn't use, but there was
always an inkling of a thought.
Well, I've been only sober eight days.
Some people might comment and say,
well you only got eight days.
What about day number nine?
You know what?
I'm gonna take it a day at a time,
if I may be cliche ish.
- [Mark] I mean, there's
no arrogance right now.
- I mean, just do it, Norman.
- [Mark] There's no
arrogance in you right now.
It's all humility.
- Yeah, just take it a day at a time.
I mean, you put a video.
I don't know if this company
that's gonna video has seen it.
I don't know.
- [Mark] Now I'd be
more likely to hire you
if I had seen it.
- And if they did, I'm gonna
tell them, yeah that's me.
And I know they're more
than likely going to ask,
do you still have that problem?
Well, it's not so much of a problem.
You'll always have the disease,
but it can be arrested.
It can be put to death.
And the only way it can be put to death
is just following God's
will because he already,
see the book has been written already.
Front to end.
So now I'm in chapter one.
And the reason why I'm in chapter one is
because I'm restructuring,
recreating and redoing my life.
So now I'm in chapter one.
So chapter one basically has
instructions that I have to do.
So I'm just following
day by day, you know.
I've never experienced this
much humility in my life.
I'm humble as a piece
of cheese on a rat trap.
I'm just, you know, I'm like, ah.
It's like when I did that interview,
it was like, here's a,
they just start getting off.
You know?
And I just, I felt different when I left.
Did I use that day?
Hell yeah, I used that day.
But it wasn't, it was something wrong.
It wasn't the dope.
It was me.
And my buddy, he went, man, you all right?
I'm like, yeah, I'm okay.
But I wasn't okay.
That night I stirred around.
I wasn't okay.
Next day, I stirred inside.
Wasn't okay.
And it was like, it's time.
That's what I heard.
It's time.
The time is now.
I'm like okay.
So, so what if I'm 56 years
old and starting again?
Damned if you do and damned if you don't.
And it was a phrase that
my grandmother used to use.
She said, sweetheart,
whatever you do in life,
do it to the best of your ability.
And if nobody else likes
it, mother had them,
mother love them, and mother fuck them.
In saying that, I had to really understand
what she was saying.
Don't worry because they're
going to be the naysayers.
It's like the Sadducees and the Pharisees.
See it's just like this, that is now.
It's like the same thing.
So you're gonna have them.
What are you gonna do?
Are you gonna succumb to their
thoughts and feelings of you?
People have their own attitudes,
values, beliefs and prejudices.
That's just how it is.
That's life.
So you know what?
I'm gonna take it a day at a time,
do the best that I can do.
And I would really like to
ascertain a job, come in here
and do an interview in a suit.
- [Mark] I'd like to have
you back about 50 times.
- Oh yeah.
I'll be back as much as you want.
You have my phone number.
People out there, you
have my phone number.
You can call me, you can text me.
You know, I have a phone
that I haven't sold.
Isn't that something?
I don't give a damn if
it's an Obama phone.
Shit, it got to go too if I need a hit.
But I have a phone so
I can contact people,
so people can contact me.
You know, those comments
really, really, I'll be damned.
It's about, it's almost
a thousand right now.
And I'll read them over and over again.
- [Mark] There's a lot
of positivity out there.
- I get teary-eyed every time, you know,
but there's all, you can do it.
You can do it.
- [Mark] So many of the people I interview
will get similar kind of
reactions from the commenters,
but they won't allow
themselves to read them.
- I read them and I comment.
- [Mark] And that's the
big indicator for whether-
- I say, thank you.
You know, I...
- [Mark] And that's a big indicator of
whether they're ready to get clean.
Because if you're not willing
to accept that positivity,
you're not gonna.
- Yeah, you're fucked.
- [Mark] You're screwed.
- You're fucked. You might as well.
- [Mark] But the fact that you're like,
like you and Eric, another guy I speak to,
the fact that you guys
engage in the comments
tells me that yes, you're
you're already healed.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You're just gonna
follow through with that.
And in a year, it'll be
a very different story.
- Yeah. I'm just gonna keep on going,
and as many times as you want
to see me, you got my number.
I'll be on here.
I mean, you know, somebody
else may be suffering.
I'm not gonna say like I've suffered,
but like I'm suffering.
See God, I want to make sure
that the -ing stays in there
because the -ed is his job.
There's a difference between
recovering and recovered.
You know, one guy he mentioned on there,
well, he's using all the treatment...
Well, okay, if you've been
in 54 treatment centers,
of course you can remember some shit.
You know, but here's a book
that I'm gonna start following
that was written in 1936
by Bill Wilson.
But I'm in that book.
Now, how the hell am I in a
book that's written in 1936?
Same behaviors, same
beliefs, same actions.
Just because Bill drank like he drank,
I smoked like I smoked.
Basically, I smoked like bill drank.
- [Mark] What's the book?
- Alcoholics anonymous.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- Excellent book.
Excellent book.
It doesn't get enough credit.
Written in Akron, Ohio in 1936.
It's unbelievable.
I'm born in 1964.
I'm sitting before you in 2020,
but I'm about to follow the instructions
and the guidelines of
a book written in 1936.
Why? Because I'm in it.
Take the alcohol,
just put a line through
the alcohol, put crack.
Exactly the same.
You know, exactly the same.
Page 52, middle paragraph,
it says selfish is self-centered,
that which is the root of all our problems
driven by a hundred forms of fear.
Self-delusional, we step
on the toes of our fellows
and they retaliate seemingly
without provocation.
What we invariably find
that some point in the past,
we made a decision based on self
which later on put ourselves
in a position to be hurt.
That has stuck in my mind
for the last eight days.
You know why?
Because I found that at
some point in the past,
July 19th, 1986,
I made a decision based on self,
which later on, here I am 2020,
put me in a position to be hurt.
Hurt how?
Hungry, homeless,
jobless, afraid, hopeless.
Now I'm hopeful.
It's gonna be a damn good ride.
And I just thank God for
giving me the strength
and his empowerment and his wherewithal
to have me sitting right here.
Eight days consecutive with nothing.
- [Mark] So great.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Norman, thank you so much, man.
- Hey, no problem.
None at all.
Thank you bro.
- [Mark] It's beautiful.
- [Norman] We gonna do this man.
- [Mark] Good for you, man.
- [Norman] It's gonna be all right, bro.
It's gonna be all right.